SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: Formativos de las partes. Si los niños y fuertes por llevar a cabo y todo igual forma, el acusado
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: no me vierten la asistencia de la víctima. No obstante, la mirada
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: no informado se instala la audiencia
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: previo siempre ingresar al juicio propiamente considerado. La ley 586 a efectos de las salidas alternativas, el ministerio público pudo conversar con la parte. Sí, señor Juez: Buenas tardes, efectivamente.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: conversación sostenida que el imputado o ha manifestado someterse fuertemente a
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: y que se le imponga la pena privativa de libertad de 3 años.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: Muy bien. Tiene la palabra. Gracias
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: al efecto del Presidente, cuiscieron los datos prácticos de la acusación
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: contra Miguel Mier Alfaro. Dan cuenta que en su tiempo convivía con Claudia paniagua con quien, después de una serie de circunstancias, llegan a separarse más. Sin embargo.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: a pesar de estar separados en fecha 2 de mayo a
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: este señor al promediar
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: la hora 20, aproximadamente, llega al domicilio donde se alquilaba. Digo el inmueble donde alquilaba un ambiente, un cuarto, la víctima, claudia paniagua
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: y quien preside bueno estando descansando, descansando la víctima sorprendida por el en por el imputado que empieza a proferir una serie de ofensas y, además.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: inferirle agresiones físicas, inclusive con un arma corto punzante.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: Luego la señora es auxiliada por vecinos y las la propia dueña del domicilio, siendo trasladado a un nosocomio donde ha recibido este atención médica por el término de 2 años.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: perdón, 2 días.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: 2 días Este, sin embargo, posteriormente, también, estando la señora transitando por la calle aroma nuevamente es interceptado por el prenombrado, donde es amenazado, de que si fuera denunciado, podría inclusive atentar contra su vida.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: Estos son, en esencia y resumen, los datos fácticos que hacen que dan cuenta que el imputado efectivamente este cometió el ilícito. Subsumiendo su conducta, los elementos constitutivos del tipo penal previsto en el artículo 200, 72 bis
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: en sus 2 elementos. El elemento
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: en violencia psicológica y violencia, así demuestra la documentación de prueba documental que se tiene como efecto de la carga probatoria que lo fundamental entre ellos se encuentra el certificado médico forense de 4 de mayo del año, 2 000. Dieciocho
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: Pues bien.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: estando en estas circunstancias, la ley 586 refiere que el imputado puede son perdón. La ley 586 hace énfasis en que el ministerio público, como la con la autoridad jurisdiccional. Siempre debemos tratar de privilegiar las salidas alternativas en la perspectiva de que la pronta solución al conflicto.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: La misma que tiene coherencia con el artículo 3 26 del procedimiento penal cuando señala que el imputado puede someterse a cualquier salida alternativa incluso hasta antes que se dicta la sentencia, como en el caso presente se basaba, se está promoviendo a
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: la salida alternativa de procedimiento abreviar que tiene una vinculación con el artículo 373 del procedimiento penal. Cuando el imputado ha denunciado
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: al juicio un oral público y contradictorio, está reconociendo que él es el autor de la comisión del delito que se le acusa y, naturalmente, también en conversación a
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: y noticia con el abogado defensor. Este
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: solicitado se le imponga la pena privativa de libertad de 3 años de privación, de libertad máxima que Quantum, de la pena abierta del tipo penal en referencia. La pena mínima es de 2 años
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: y la máxima es de 4 años. Por consiguiente, promueve esta salida alternativo conforme a los antecedentes fácticos y jurídicos que tengo a bien expresar pidiendo sus propiedades reiteradamente, tenga a bien aceptada la misma y se dicte la sentencia condenatoria con la pena privativa de libertad de 3 años. Gracias, señor José.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: Se tiene presente.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: Mhm.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: a ver de pie, señor Miguel, Primeramente, me
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: vas a proporcionar tus datos. Dame nombre, apellidos, completos. Miguel Ángel ni el miedo al foro
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: número de cédula de identidad. Trece 19 32 23
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: lugar y fecha de nacimiento se acaba del 15 de julio
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: del 1 993
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: de junio o julio julio, julio.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: estado civil soltero
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: a qué te dedicabas o qué hacías vendía dulces.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: dónde estabas viviendo tu domicilio en la situación de calle.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: Desde nosotros
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: a ver. Miguel, Has escuchado al fiscal sobre los hechos.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: estás aceptando libre y voluntariamente someterte a esta a este procedimiento abreviado. Sí,
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: estás denunciando ir a un juicio oral, público y contradictorio, Sí,
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: por otro lado, también sobre esos hechos que has escuchado, ¿Estás admitiendo también haber participado en el mismo ¿Sí?
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: Y la pena que se te va a imponer son de 3 años, también estás de acuerdo? Sí,
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: Muy bien. Toma asiento.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: doctor Carmelín, tiene la palabra. Muchas gracias, señor Vasco. Uso la palabra en principio, es ayudar a su digna autoridad y a los sujetos profesores dentro de la presente audiencia.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: Sí, Después, esta parte se va a adherir a los requeridos por el ministerio público, pues es cierto, su autoridad ha podido advertir en la presente audiencia, se ha cumplido a cabalidad. Lo presentó en el artículo 373 siguientes del Código de procedimiento penal, pues mi defendido a viva voz ha aceptado
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: La Comisión del ilícito, ha aceptado las condiciones y los términos del procedimiento abreviado, por lo que, señor juez, a fin de no cansar a su digna autoridad. Voy a soltar a su digna autoridad. Se acepto la salida alternativa de procedimiento abreviado en contra de mi defendido del señor Miguel Niera alfaro en la pena de 3 años en el penal que su autoridad considere pertinente. Muchas gracias, señor juez
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: y en su primer
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: proceder a dictar la resolución vistos
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: de la solicitud de salida alternativa de procedimiento penal imputado por el Ministerio público
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: los fundamentos expuestos en la presente audiencia.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: así como también he escuchado la parte imputada.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: Quien acepta libre y voluntariamente y da un procedimiento breve de renunciar el juicio de la República y contradictorio
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: aceptar su voluntad de manera voluntaria, su culpabilidad y participación en el hecho acusado.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: así como también de la pena imponerse.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: Su defensa. También está de acuerdo con la solicitud del Ministerio Público.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: lo que permite advertir que se han cumplido los requisitos de los artículos 373 siguientes en el artículo 326 del código del procedimiento penal, por lo que se admite la solicitud de procedimiento abreviado.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: solicitado y a favor de Miguel Ángel Muñoz Alfaro.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: por lo que sepa proceder a dictar las respectiva sentencia.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: Mis 2 de requerimiento con la presente audiencia de juicio oral
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: y de parte del ministerio público
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: de la salida alternativa de procedimiento abreviado, los mandamientos expuestos, así como también he escuchado al imputado a su defensa
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: los antecedentes del grupo, pues, se están considerando primero
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: que la presente audiencia el ministerio público.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: conforme su solicitud de procedimiento enviado de precisar que y presente hecho.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: esa es por el delito de violencia familiar y doméstica y sus 2 elementos de violencia física y psicológica.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: Ese acusado a Miguel Ángel Miguel alfaro
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: por hechos que habrían acontecido en fecha 2 de mayo del año. Dos 1 020,
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: en circunstancias que ahora 20, m.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: Cuando la víctima Claudia Paniagua se encontraba descansando su cuarto
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: ubicado en la Avenida Siles y Huayna Capag
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: De haber sido sorprendida por su ex concubino, Miguel Mier.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: quien se encontraba en estado de ebriedad y había ingresado por la pared para proceder, en su caso, agredirla
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: físicamente, con un cuchillo ocasionándole lesiones en sus brazos, piernas, manos
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: y, consiguientemente, ante este hecho de haber sido socorrida por los vecinos y se trasladaron a nosocomio de A
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: del Hospital Cochabamba, donde habría sido internada por 2 días, hechos sobre los cuales claramente
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: serían los que se acusa por el delito de violencia familiar doméstica y que en el presente
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: acorde a esos fundamentos expuestos claramente de establecer.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: respecto a la conducta de la parte imputada sobre el delito, locusado
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: a su turno. También la parte importante de aceptar libre y voluntariamente la salida alternativa de procedimiento madrileñado de renunciar e ir a un juicio oral, público y contradictorio, así como también
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: de su participación en los hechos.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: que es lo que son como autor y
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: le da pena imponerse su abogado de adhericia. La solicitud del Ministerio Público en razón de haberse cumplido
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: lo previsto en los artículos 2, 73, 274 del código de procedimiento penal.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: considerando segundo qué efecto, siempre de considerar la serie alternativa
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: dentro de ese marco que establece
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: la misma normativa con la penalidad de descongestionar la sobrecarga procesal y buscaron eficacia en la persecución penal
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: a través de una rápida solución al conflicto penal
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: conforme a los fundamentos expuestos por el Ministerio Público y
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: acorde a los elementos de prueba que se tiene en el caso.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: Podemos ser un informe preliminar.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: El investigador asignado al caso sargento. Segundo, en el instituto en Galicia
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: de fecha 7 de mayo del año. Dos 1 018 se transmite a los hechos posiciones investigativas ya avanzadas.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: Por otro lado, también es Acta de denuncia verbal
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: realizada por parte de Claudia Paniagua
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: que la misma desde el de 5 de mayo del año, 2 018 y en
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: donde también se establecen los hechos que vienen acontecido.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: Otro elemento, también de tener su certificado médico forense.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: donde se establece días de incapacidad a Claudia, paniagua de 12 días.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: y también de tener ese referente a los antecedentes penales
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: del imputado Miguel Ángel mierda elementos con los que el Ministerio público de tarifa sobre la existencia del hecho
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: y consiguientemente, de cuyo análisis también resolverse a establecer
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: que conducen al sustituto juzgador al convencimiento de que
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: el acusado Miguel Ángel Mier alfaro
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: es el autor del delito de violencia familiar doméstica previsto y sancionado artículo, 2,
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: 72 bis del Código Penal.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: Esas son de haberse establecido con suficientes elementos de prueba
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: que acreditarán su responsabilidad y participación del imputado en el hecho acusado, considerándose
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: qué efectos de la presente solicitud de amerita siempre remitis a la normativa, entre ellos el artículo 3 26 referente a las salidas alternativas y los artículos 3 73 374 del código de procedimiento penal referente
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: a la presente solicitud.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: que en el presente caso, conforme se establece de los fundamentos expuestos por el Ministerio público, Mhm.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: que ha logrado acreditar con prome idónea cartulina referente
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: a la existencia del hecho público y la participación del imputado
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: en el delito de violencia familiar o doméstica, prestación del artículo, 272 bis del código penal.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: A su vez, también
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: el mismo imputado de manera libre y voluntaria, expresado su deseo de someterse a una salida alternativa de renunciar y a juicio, oración al público y contradictorio, así como también de su participación y autoría en un hecho acusado y de la pena imponerse a
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: todo de manera voluntaria. Si 1 pensar de él, adherirse a los ojos, sin duda de las abiertos latina
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: hechos y fundamentos que claramente denotan
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: referente a la responsabilidad del imputado sobre dicho cursado
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: y, consiguientemente, establecer el frente a su autobio
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: y afectos, siempre de considerar también a los atenuantes generales y especiales. El militar reductis en sus artículos, 38, 39 y 40 del Código
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: Penal.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: Por tanto, ¿qué juez de sentencia penal anticorrupción y contra la violencia hacia las mujeres de Andalucía.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: conforme a los fundamentos expuestos y administrando justicia. En primera instancia, declara al acusado Miguel
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: Miguel Ángel Miel Alfaro de las Generales conocidas en la presente audiencia
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: del procedimiento mediado autor y culpable de la Comisión del delito de violencia familiar o doméstica previsto sancionar al artículo 30,
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: 272 bits del código final y, consiguientemente.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: conforme al artículo 365
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: de pronunciar sentencia condenatoria en su contra de imponer una pena privativa de libertad de 3 años de ejecución a cumplir en el asiento penitenciario de el abra de las localidades acaba
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: más el pago de costas, daños perjuicios averiguados en la ejecución de sentencias
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: Ministerio público va a hacer sus denuncias. Renunciamos a plazos.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: 131 hacemos el anuncio expresa de los curas procesales de alteración restringida y vamos a solicitar la ejecutoría y que se extienda el mandamiento de condenas. Muchas gracias.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: Muy bien habiendo escuchado las partes tanto al ministerio público, así como también
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: a la defensa del imputado de dictar el respectivo complementario, habiendo renunciado los plazos procesados de impugnación a que tienen derecho tanto el Ministerio público, así como también la Defensa.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: en aplicación de lo previsto en el artículo 126 le corresponde declarar ejecutoriada la sentencia dimitida de procedimiento abreviado.
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: en su caso, debiendo remitirse antecedentes al registro judicial de antecedentes penales conforme al artículo 440
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: y, consiguientemente, también ante el juez de ejecución penal y disponer a su vez, se expide el respectivo mandamiento de condena en contra del acusado
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: a efectos de que cumpla su condena en el recinto penitenciario de él habra
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: y debiendo notificarse a su vez, al director del referido, es decir, tú,
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: y quedar notificadas las partes con la presente resolución también, que resuelva la ejecutoria y de haber concluido la
SECRETARI@ JSPACVM 7: no, muchas gracias.